he was in the 2016 presidential race for
the Republican candidate for president
he is the author of two paths America
divided or United he's also the Governor
of Ohio John Kasich is over here
how you doing governor great to meet you
thank you for coming by I I think our
audience agrees with me you're one of
the good ones look at that that's pretty
good for a little California audience so
let's really get them on your side and
talk about some of the things that
you've done in or for first of all you
supported medical marijuana in Ohio
correct well we did it because we felt
that we were going to get a say yes no
I'll tell you I'll tell you what bill
might here's my concern about it and I
know you legalized it here for
recreational reasons but you know we
have this big opiate problem as you know
and nothing to do with pot no but here's
what here's what here's what I'm
concerned about the Drug Enforcement
agents came to see me they're like you
know it's been in the 25 28 32 years and
I said what do we do what do we do about
this that you know because we are on top
of everything and I wanted to hear from
them and they said look John what we
have to do is educate people starting at
a very early age and we have to drive
this all the way through because you
know the opiates become harder to get
and then people head to heroin and my
only concern about the marijuana issue
is I don't want to tell kids don't do
drugs but you could then do this drug so
that is the point but in Ohio we have a
medical marijuana I signed the bill to
get that done well why do I have to
bring kids into it I mean liquor is
legal and we don't tell kids you can
have liquor I don't know why that always
has to enter into the debate yeah I mean
I don't know why
an entire nation of adults has to be
deputized into the fight for parents to
keep their kids away from drugs or guns
or their sex toys you know what you're
you're built like all I be smarter than
your head all I'm saying to you is okay
you have an enormous problem you know it
we all know it yes oh we see these
opiates which then leads to this problem
of heroin and fentanyl which is deadly
and all I want to do is tell the kids in
an early age and all the way through
school reinforcing their parents or
reinforcing anybody in this audience who
doesn't want to see a kid destroy their
lives and I and so what I'm saying to
you is I just don't want to be confusing
but we have a medical marijuana right
why and you also expanded medical that
it want to Medicaid which a lot of
Republican governors did not feel part
of Obamacare because you know you care a
lot about the poor it's part of your
faith is it not yeah well look they came
in to me one day they said we can cover
700,000 people who are either mentally
ill drug addicted or chronically ill a
third of the 700,000 either have a drug
problem or they're mentally ill and
frankly how do you say no to that and it
is a partnership with the federal
government I think Medicaid expansion
can be can be changed to some degree but
we don't want to do it overnight because
where are those people going to go okay
and that's not appropriate and I want
people to have health care and I'll tell
you another thing it is very important
for both parties not just a Republican
party but both parties the easiest thing
to do is to run over the weak those who
live in the shadows and those who don't
have much and it is not right and part
of my faith is I mean that doesn't sound
like most Republicans it doesn't mean
you are out of step with your team you
say that all right I mean that is a
comma wait a minute maybe I'm truck mitt
no no what I'm saying is maybe I'm
trying to define what my party ought to
be I wish someone moved
yeah now there used to be I mean I
didn't I wasn't a big fan of George Bush
but when he said compassionate
conservative and by the way he looks
better all the time now he does no still
not good but better ok what Jack Kemp
you know there were there was you know
Republican classic I would call them
well I think you are in that school well
and you think about not just somebody
like like Jack Kemp but you even think
back to JFK who said a rising tide lifts
all boats I mean we want to have
everybody in our country believe first
of all that people care about them
because there are many people in this
country who think nobody cares about me
and I don't matter and that is not
healthy and secondly you want to give
people a chance to rise and if they have
bad health they can't get work they
can't have anything so go and by the way
did you know as you know I've been I've
been very forceful on this health care
bill and I have spoken out against it
and it but you see people are focusing
on the pre-existing conditions which
they should and what they do is let's
allow states to opt out of that
requirement I don't know any states that
will but the problem is not just that
the problem is bigger than that bill the
problem is there is not the resources in
this bill to help people on the exchange
some people would get no more than a
three or four thousand dollar tax credit
what can you buy for a health care
policy and if you are mentally ill or
drug-addicted you have to go to the
doctor all the time and you've got your
deductibles and they don't have any
money so I'm hoping that the United
States Senate will get in this and fix
this all of it and make it better
so I think what Obamacare did more than
anything was changed America's view of
health care that it's a right but your
party says it's a product it's a product
like any other product and I don't want
to pay for you buying something that you
should buy beyond yourself so let me ask
you is it a right or is it a product
one-word answer only okay is it a right
or a product look I would I would okay I
would say it's a right if you forced me
to choose one of the other but hold on
hold on hold on Senator Robert Taft who
was a senator voted one of the five best
senators it was in Senate from 1939 to
1950 three years later Ohio State well
here's what he said he said if people
can't afford health care in our country
the United States of America the
government ought to get it for them now
I don't know how we went from mr.
conservative mr. Republican to where if
I say that people need to have coverage
that somehow that makes me something
other than acceptable to conservatives I
think conservatives ought to understand
that it is important for every
individual every person to have the hope
to be able to rise and get ahead now
bill hold on one other thing I want to
say this issue of the health insurance
and covering people fine get them their
coverage we need to do that but we have
to work on the rising cost of health
care which means we have to change the
way pharmaceutical industry
pharmaceutical industry sells us stuff
we have to think about we have to think
about transparency we need to know who's
providing we need to pay doctors and
hospitals for quality how about we
wrapping the gouging I agree with that I
mean there's got to be some cash well
I'll tell you what I went in and I know
that's anti-republican okay so I have a
right to define it just as much as
anybody absolutely oh thank you yeah
here's the thing though what I suggested
to the administration and I believe this
at home I and this is what that's what
the Democrats gave me I have to put
every drug on my formulary regardless of
cost you know what I want I want the
ability to take them off my formulary I
want leverage I want them to bring their
price down now we don't want to destroy
the industry because hey they may be
creating something that's going to save
somebody's life here you know and avoid
invasive surgery or whatever but you
cannot have something like EpiPen Jack
their prices exactly and so you know I'm
a believer in a free enterprise system
but I also believe it has to be under
laid with a set of values and that's the
great theologian Michael Novak who laid
that okay but I don't think a lot of
people in your party including Paul Ryan
even understand how insurance works I
read a quote from him last week on the
show where he said well the problem with
Obamacare is that you have young people
paying for old people's health care of
course that's how insurance works and
when they get to be old than young
people will pay for them now they want
this high-risk pool they want to put all
the people at high risk in one pool this
is like marrying your parent you don't
yeah you want a mixture you want the
young healthy people in with the older
sicker people not a high well that's a
little bit them the problem was is that
Obamacare because of the way they
changed the insurance market it made it
harder for young people to buy insurance
the cost was too high and so the pools
have not been healthy and we need to
make sure that we have healthy pools
with both young people who are healthy
and other people who are sick in terms
of the issue of pre-existing conditions
there would be no excuse no excuse I can
think of an America that somebody who
has a pre-existing condition has to ever
worry about getting health care that
would be outrageous okay so I mean
everything you say
sound so so reasonable but you said it
as a candidate last time yeah and it
didn't fly so but I guy who's not very
reasonable kicked your ass yeah let's
beyond that's right so let me present a
scenario to you now it's only been a
hundred days with Donald Trump let's say
two years down the road I can see a
scenario where he's in a lot of trouble
because he's an idiot he there could be
a foreign affairs disaster he doesn't
know anything about that Russia could
explode in his face people could be
dying from his healthcare bill I could
see a challenge in the Republican Party
for 2020 would you be up for that
you know no no look you wouldn't
shaolong than as a sitting president
that's so it's so speculative and I'm
look I'm I'm going to finish my term in
18 months as governor of our state
pull the state together and get it to do
better and better and better that's what
I'm all about
and giving everybody a shot and then I
don't know what I'm going to do I'm
going to keep a voice but I can't
predict to you I never thought I would
be governor I never thought I'd go back
into politics so what I look for is what
is it I'm supposed to do what is it I'm
supposed to do in my lifetime to build a
better world or build a better community
or whatever and so I can't tell you what
that's going to be and I'm not plotting
it's gaming I'm rooting for him to do
well bill the same reason why I root for
a pilot on my airplane to do well okay
he's the president
but he's not selling well he's not Sully
that's a good line yeah okay at this but
look if we want to have a president that
unites us not a president that but you
famously made a statement about not
voting for him not I did work I did and
it was a statement of integrity because
it was hard to do at that time it's
within your party I'm just saying
somebody in your party needs to stick up
for the classic Republican well I'm
doing it all the time banging in
aggregate we approve you know aggravate
some people not necessarily them not up
and look part of that election was I was
like a Ugandan swimmer I was so far to
the right side of the stage no one could
even see me and then in order to get
attention bill you know holistic I'll
have to google that analogy after the
show he remember never watch the
Olympics like that was a great thing
okay but it's a really good thing I'll
send you tainted do so I was way out on
the end but here's the thing what I
didn't want to do seriously what I
didn't want to do and this is a problem
with and I love the media but this is
one of the problems you call somebody a
name you have this clever soundbite and
then you're on the Morning News I wasn't
going to do that I mean I represent
eleven and a half million people but you
see a lot of people want to look for
that they want to that's what they
absorb and that is not the way we should
be picking presidents on may I'll bite
let's make America diction again right
yeah thank you very much
that's a lot in the future
Governor Kasich alright ladies on